carpentras ce n'est pas la première fois
ces dix dernières années plusieurs
cimetières juifs ont été profanées et on
trouve souvent sur des façades dans
toute la france des graffitis qui disent
faurisson a raison celui qui nie
l'existence des chambres à gaz ou encore
les juifs dehors en continu et 183 bis
chaîne dans le bas-rhin 40 tombe
renversé dans le cimetière israélite le
bas-rhin lederer affirme avoir vu les
hauteurs de jeunes vandales dit il une
semaine avant le même cimetière avait
déjà été saccagés problème actuel est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus ça mon avis
la différence ou de la cazine le quasi
manque de réaction des gens devant
quelque forme de brutalité qui peut
s'exercer
aucune réaction n'aura permis en tout
cas d'éviter un scénario semblable se
reproduise un an plus tard à nice
soixante quatre tombes détruites à coups
de masse cette fois les auteurs viennent
de la mouvance d'extrême droite ont 88
la série continue en alsace en avril à
weiterswiller dans le bas-rhin 80
diplômes sont renversés dans le
cimetière israélite trois adolescents
seront présentés au juge pour enfants de
strasbourg un mois après c'est le
cimetière de sarre union pour le même
département qui est touché ici c'est la
deuxième fois en deux ans un rappeur
résurgence d'antisémitisme qui tord
remet en marche un peu partout on fait
passer pour d'autres encore l'an dernier
dans le pas de calais les inscriptions
nazies dans un cimetière saccagé deux
jeunes gens avouent ils se réclament de
l'idéologie extrémiste des skinheads
dans l'est le midi les hauts-de-seine où
ailleurs cette semaine encore à
wissembourg d' la liste des cimetières
profanés est longue mais jamais on avait
atteint l'horreur découverte hier à
carpentras